can't let's talk about them live shows
baby that middle-class famous tour
that's a good good time that
middle-class famous tour we're coming to
a city near you it's a stand-up comedy
show then we play a little ayg with the
crowd fantastic way to introduce new
people to the show grab your best guy
grab your best gal grab your girlfriends
grab your guy friends bring the whole
squad and come see us yeah gang next
week uh september 13th we're going to be
in kansas city then september 14th we're
going to be in springfield all right
then in september 15th we're going to be
in st louis then in october coming to
nashville we're going to indy november
we're going to philly's second show out
of there that's almost sold out get
those tickets don't sleep on that then
we're coming to providence rhode island
and boston in december those shows are
sold out at the moment but we're adding
tickets be on the lookout yeah
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage hey little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they go to be classy but
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash i'm your host dave foley coming at
you on a bit of a somber day down here
at antonio basement what happened she's
very upset god ozzy's moving back to
england she thought she had a shot i
know
she's all bummed out yeah he signed her
titty at a concert a few years ago and
that was it okay my cowos is coming at
you from across the table it's a family
episode he is the ceo of argue garbage
he is an international businessman he is
the prince of park avenue but always the
king of the boards baby yeah give it up
for mr steele your girl 2003 kj kevin
james ryan all right what's up everybody
the ladies man back in high school here
joe okay um
uh somebody was mr steal your girl who
was it it was usher or something that
was like somebody's nickname back in the
day aka mr steal your girl that's what
i'm talking how's kippy doing his puff
daddy karaoke
being around uh what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are
out
then obviously i'd be remiss i mean i
don't know
there's a lot of things cooking around
here with hoodies recently not to
mention a mess she's got going up there
but
i mean the youtube numbers drew the roof
cooking right the audio numbers through
the roof those live shows sold out whoa
i mean shout out to seattle and portland
but there is nothing quite as white hot
as that [ __ ] patreon.com slash
are you garbage thank you mr conte and
mystery check
baby shout out to the [ __ ] army of
garbage all the generals on there
appreciate it love the [ __ ] support
y'all are the best and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he works the ones and twos
he crosses the he dots the eyes
spins all the hits does the drive time
give it up for tebow mcmuffin toby
mcmullen everybody what's up dudes hey
t-bone trey songz mr seal yo girl
mr steal your girl i believe it too
yikes
by the way i called i was mr steal your
hot dog
mr steal your lunch
[Laughter]
i bet you did a little trading back in
the day got your hands on something
you're nuts
you're such a weird fat kid man it's so
strange you're a weird fat man but yeah
no not i'm traditional
i like the normal things that a normal
fat guy would eat but you weren't like a
big sweets guy back in i mean this is
this is old hat we've gone over this but
yeah you got fat on rolls that's nuts
yeah carbs you actually you actually
was just skittles that got you fat all
right well
they were i was a combination you're
having pancakes 10 times a week a month
ago i had a little bit of a more
creative palette i would say like
because you like candy it's not like you
got fat eating filet mignon you chubster
i'm the royal yeah i was i was arlington
every day
you've been eating [ __ ] you eat
everything yes i do yeah
i was a picky eater picky eater yeah i
like my buttered noodles yeah i like my
peanut butter sandwiches i like my
chicken nuggies i like french fries
barbecue sauce
not until my teenage years that was the
palette you were like taco bell
never i don't know i don't [ __ ] with
taco bell no i mean you made a bunch of
[ __ ] with small ingredients oh yeah yeah
so yeah what i was going to say i saw
that uh what did you say i saw the
documentary of the the and one doc
shout out to hot sauce man
hot sizzle professor the professor
i remember when that [ __ ] that was like
i can i had no i completely i thought i
thought first of all
i used to be able to do some of the
moves
[Laughter]
get me a rock some tebow hit me
i'm not fat there's a basketball in my
shirt i was i could do that one hey yo
you guys also great at halftime if you
want to wear like a 4x to pull that move
off
you got to be kidding me
i had no idea that that completely i
remember the shorts i guess i didn't
know that they were a separate company i
thought nike owned that yeah i thought
that was like an offshoot
by the time that came on my radar those
my dad was wearing those i have a pair
of hands shorts now i can get into this
all right i i had a pair of those that
my dad wore to play racquetball your dad
was rocking n1 gear to racket yeah dude
give it up for honey mustard everybody
he never moved i played with him once or
twice he would just stand there and rip
the ball about 4 000 miles an hour yeah
those old timers learn how to hit it
hard and where to put it because they
don't like moving no not at all man he
ran me ragged
talking [ __ ] the whole time through
running his mouth
yeah
yeah i was big back in the day i was in
huge it was so good early high school
probably early 2000s is when it hit like
really big and i remember like i
remember those dvds going around like we
would get our hands on the dvd like oh
[ __ ] i got volume four volume five you
know what a headquarters was
i didn't i did not know that right
outside it was our you know was our
stomping grounds started in philly yeah
first one was in linden new jersey well
they did the first one it was like a
couple people there then they were
selling out stadiums and they were in
europe backing it out though i know
pretty sweet man
that's a tough gig has this been
business corner where they
i heard their uh gross domestic revenue
was over 200 million dollars did you
know anybody that tried out that's what
what are you talking about i could see
some of your buddies cry out yeah they
had tryouts
yeah no we weren't trying out first of
all we were like 14 from bucks county
the professor was young
yeah but he had handles
crush you up he's still big online right
now snap your septum i follow him on
tick tock you do he still goes he still
goes to the [ __ ] court and balls out
really
well now it's a thing
because he was so big i think he you
know pivoted and now he's like huge on
youtube i think is like or all social
media but i think he's got a really big
tick tock channel and he goes places and
it's like now you try to beat the
professor nice but if you're wearing n1
now sounds like a patreon goal to me
tough luck oh we get the professor out
here run some [ __ ] games you out
there
that'd be pretty sweet i'd probably
score a couple i'd back them down now
when does that come back in the style
now for the kids and what and why and
one's a tough luck you think yeah now
like but it could come because
everything's cyclical it could be cool
yeah we're gonna come back because the
kids the kids are wearing them uh
that shit's all ironic the new what does
that mean though you're still wearing it
how was that you're wearing it because
it's not cool yeah it's not what the
cool kids are wearing right but then it
is what the cool kids are wearing sure
so we could do that for and one maybe
i'll try to bring it back there you go i
think i got a shot is this you telling
me you bought n1 shorts that's what i
think this whole [ __ ] thing is
might be a couple charges on the amex
might be questionable
i'd get the sneaks i remember the sneaks
a couple of associates of mine used to
wear them
older gentlemen
gigolos what do you mean drug dealers
you're going to old drug dealers you had
a couple older guys yeah older guys
what's up larry
can't call it
that's almost verbatim
yeah he used to use that he was a big
ringtone guy oh he's a one dude real big
ringtone guy
oh man good times yeah good times
anywho uh i did want to ask you one
thing before we get started as you know
gangplay this is a uh
family episode i thought we lost you for
a second
me and debo made eye contact in that
moment as a go boy yeah you've been
making a lot of eye contact too i see
that going on yeah i'm getting old and
getting old and see that
you'll never as you think we're after
yet
you're gonna put me in a home
i'm going to come in orderlies are going
to come in with a big net to get you
next thing you know i'm sitting playing
checkers with some guy wearing a helmet
i don't like it we got a headset mic on
you we pipe you in
hey applesauce hit the intro
i gotta go it's enchilada tonight
the [ __ ] out of here
oh [ __ ]
gang it's a family episode as you know
when you sign up for the patreon you get
your question right on the air but
before we get i can't believe we just
did like a business run down and what
that was like a documentary review
[ __ ] jim creamer over here let's go
[ __ ] crazy mad money
that guy sucks
hey cue balls
he got caught like embezzling and [ __ ]
now he's still on tv i caught that get
out of here i caught that in the hotel
in seattle i'm like this [ __ ] he was all
he was on every channel that [ __ ] guy
i'm trying to sit there well i was
trying to watch him stay by the bellerin
there's bozo still calling in like what
are you nuts i know yeah jesus buy
weapons what are you doing
[ __ ] listen to this guy brick and
mortar baby let's do it
anyway before we get into that i was
going to ask you were you a pork loin
family growing up i again i guess this
goes back
i know you didn't [ __ ] with it i think
so uh yeah i remember loin i remember
everything pork loin was big i remember
visually seeing them
when that thing was laid out in the sink
on your way to school you know it was
going to be some good eating i remember
seeing it in a i remember the black pan
that you know that like
kind of marble looking black pan that
was big back in the day no
it's like the finish it had like white
specks it was like black oh i know what
you're talking about yeah yeah but it
had it was like uh old west kind of
cookware kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah it
was like that decorated a little bit
sure you know i remember a [ __ ] pork
loins being in that thing with like
rosemary and thyme being like get this
the [ __ ] away from me a little
sauerkraut oh i loved it little mashed
little coleslaw and some applesauce yeah
you like a pork loin love a pork loin
dude pork loins are all right that's the
filet mignon of [ __ ] uh pig meat
okay that's a way to put it
in this i'm a hoof man myself would your
family season themselves would you buy
the pre-season vacuum sealed grocery
store hatfield they were buying oh yeah
pre-seasoned buddy i already got the
undercoating right it's already cooked
too
slide that thing i think we did get a
couple that were cooked
because i remember put it on the hood
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] shout out to a pork loin
delicious good meal i had uh
i had a bit of a tray she it's one of
those things cause you know inherently
we're so trashy but my card got declined
yikes where yeah um and is that going to
happen to me no it's my personal card
tough luck yikes the lady looked at me
with just such i went shout out to buy
you got a wedding come up had to buy his
suit nice um
so
not sweet tea's wedding right not tommy
c's wedding no all right you're not
buying yet right
no i mean i'm going to use the one i
just you're going to use the same suit
huh yeah yeah damn all right
uh we're gonna have to check out just
the pants please
can we let these out by the way
um
just the pants
i go so i go shopping upstairs i buy the
suit right upstairs where there's two
floors there was like men's upstairs
women's downstairs i think we're at a
banana republic maybe or yeah crew one
of them
what you're fitting in the things over
there
yeah i'm not uh dude i'm nowhere near as
big i wear an extra large okay all right
the listeners have gassed you up to
think we are the same size we are not
the same i'm not saying we're the same
size i'm just surprised you fit into
those european cuts now j crew and
banana republic aren't european okay
that's why i did not say h m or zara
okay i had to [ __ ] move up out of
there i'm an american large all right
good luck getting you into a uni club
huh
never i gotta go in the loading dock
um
but i get [ __ ] i'm there buy the suit
don't want to brag
shoot shirt all came to 700. jesus right
expensive but i got a lot of what i got
a wedding this weekend wait where'd you
start where'd you i got three weddings
in the next six weeks or something
where'd you actually get it
i forget honestly j crew or banana
republic is it uh did i think it was
banana republic does banana republic
only sell banana republic products or do
they have other designers i think it's
only banana republic banana republic
suits 700 bucks huh i think the jacket
was
i think it was like three and two or
three and three for the jacket to pants
and then a shirt i thought they were old
news maybe two i don't know huh i don't
know i honestly forget some man once hey
yo that's my nephew
um
so i buy that and i don't know anytime i
make a big purchase i'm always real
wonky i have no i have no credit card
confidence none i'm not zero i i i check
right before i wanted to but i didn't
because i wasn't going my wife's like
here let's pop in here so i was going to
i was going to go to whatever store i
was trying to go to did she lead the
charge on stuff like that what do you
mean does she pick out the outfit and
all that stuff for you yeah yeah really
that's good i mean i'm not like she's
not dressing me i have a say i'm a grown
man at the end of the day you know i
mean a lot of room in the crotch
i'm gonna have to take this in a bit
shout out to patty uh she'd give me a
karate chop right in the bowl
god damn it why were they so worried
about the crotch space in the 80s and
90s because we were too fast i know but
not once ever
from when i started behind my own pants
i ever been like there's too much room
in this crop because you're running
around the school yard and a fat [ __ ]
like you is going to rip it right down
the middle and then you're [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like this on me and not you
because you're just projected because i
i was reinforced everywhere
i was like a transformer
dude i had tough skin crotch tough
skinned knees the whole nine yards
i was like a [ __ ] look like a welder
looks like i played for the baltimore
colts
um
so i go up and um
i buy that goes through and i was a
little nervous i didn't check
right uh-huh what are you using uh can i
actually use a debit card credit card i
got a debit card debit card you don't
have a personal credit card do you i do
have a personal credit card i got uh
i got like something real bad with 200
credit limit they won't juice me and
then i got a venmo remember i pulled the
wool over venmo's eyes that's right
that's at about three grand really yeah
they moved that i think i got approved
at 2200 for the vennie and then they
bumped it to three three grand huh
yeah that's pretty good but i get that
to the broad that's her you let her yeah
yeah
really because she's got the her uh
uh she has european credit cards still
with her bank and a lot of time they
freeze it or like hey i don't know
what's going on you know exactly because
it's sure if it's used too much in the
u.s or whatever they'll just [ __ ]
spike three g's through venmo yeah is it
visa or mastercard
uh i don't know i never met the
gentleman i don't know it's got to be
one of them it can't just be a venmo
card
does it come out of your venmo no it's a
credit card
right now hold on
it should say it on it right i thought
you said it was for her oh she has it
yeah
you'd be real suspect if you had it i
haven't
i have a capital one platinum with 200
buck credit limit though no flies on you
jerk offs won't [ __ ] increase it
either yeah they play hardball i am late
for them i'm actually getting back in
their good graces my credit score is
jumping um but so i go i buy that and i
go it's one of those things where i know
i have the money in there
but i'm like still nervous and then it
[ __ ] it goes through and i'm like i
feel like i'm like i feel like i robbed
the bank you know what i mean i'm like
all right
and one for the good guys yeah go
downstairs she's like oh let me she's
looking or something like oh yeah she
bit a sweater or something like that
it's like oh yeah let's get it you know
come on
and she doesn't like spend i gotta
convince her to spend money i'm like
most guys have to tell their wives to
stop smiling i'm like [ __ ] take the
uber get this you know what i mean
um
so i'm like a big take the uber guy she
just take the um he's still taking the
subway like a [ __ ] bozo i'm like what
are you doing they're eating people's
food on us it's nuts crazy so
i uh
i go to get it so i go to get her
sweater
60 bucks something like that 540 bucks
so it's like you know
and it gets declined
too close to the sun huh pork chop like
[ __ ] and i'm like maybe i put the pin in
wrong and i know i didn't put the pin in
wrong but i tried again
declined
and now take the suit
back we're gonna add more room to this
crotch
and i'm like [ __ ]
but i got the suit in hand
and now it's getting to so sh i go i can
use another card
right but now i'm like i'm also flying
blind on other cards why don't you go to
the app on the phone and say what to
find out what the deal that's real trash
stuff hold on a second there's 10 grand
in that account oh i've done that so
many because you're a dirtbag no i go in
if if it gets declined i go in and
transfer it hang on one second i got to
move some stuff around
i didn't have the 14.99 for the bernies
let me call my offshore guy
anybody know that anyone has a country
code to switzerland by the chance it
could be skiing right now hang on
[Music]
sorry it's 8 am in china
it's a banking holiday in beijing i
think
her clothes
you know the new year
[Laughter]
year of the rat
you're the fat rat um sunday in taipei
and she hit me with
we can do multiple forms of payment if
you want and i was like i gotta say
you're splitting a sweater
it was she adds the gratuity i don't
trust them
i'm in that situation as a server and
you just have to [ __ ] own it man uh
what like
i thought she was believing i go i just
bought it upstairs it might be like a
security thing which it was but i got
the text like five minutes later in the
next store going yeah they didn't want
you robbing them that was a security
issue no
did you make this charge did you try to
make a 60 charge you're that much of a
bozo a 600 charge comes up hey is this
you no it was multiple times in the same
store okay that i within
you know five minutes or whatever all
right that they were probably like this
is weird activity okay nobody buys
multiple things in the store at the same
time
except kippy um
nobody buys a suit that's 45-28
i don't know i'm shopping for a suit it
could have been a tie something's not
added
kip i got it what neutrophil neutrophil
you know neutrophil i know you've been
using it baby who you've been talking to
yeah again you don't have to choose
between fighting hair loss and your
overall health anymore there is a
holistic solution and it is neutral fall
do yourself a favor get over there hear
what they have to say it's absolutely
fantastic you don't have to make any
compromises anymore when it comes to
your hair loss yeah uh no drugs no
compromises healthier hair and whole
body wellness that's what the good folks
over there at neutrophil are doing as a
baldy over here take my word for it act
quick if you're a young whipper snapper
out there or even if you're older and
it's thinning and it's going try give
neutral neutral fall a try it is
fantastic number one dermatologist
recommended hair growth supplement
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth thickness and visible scalp
coverage and listen it ain't all about
listen this is my world this is my room
this is my arena right now you and your
luxurious locks over there can go kick
rocks sure i'm talking to the cue balls
out there baby
this is for
even it'll stop it'll slow it down you
get you got to try to do something you
know what i mean don't just ride off
into sunset like a cue ball unless
you're like bruce willis or somebody no
drugs either no poison none of that
stuff overall body health that's what
i'm all about yes it's multi-target root
causes of thinning include stress
hormones nutrition metabolism aging
lifestyle through whole body health
physician formulated uh using new
natural medical great ingredients
neutral falls drug-free patented
technology provides consistent reliable
reliable results without compromising
your sexual health which is a big
problem with the other options
including clinical study men showed
progressive improvement in hair growth
and thickness after three to three and
six months here it goes you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to nutrafall.com
men and entering promo code garbage to
say 15 now we're talking cold hard
kitchens over here 15 bucks off your
first month subscription this is their
best offer anywhere and it's only
available to you as customers for a
limited time do it do it kip i got a
bomb bombshell for you what's that mint
mobile baby
i'm talking mint mobile fifteen dollars
a month for phone service i'm sure
you're sitting there saying what's this
fat piece of [ __ ] talking too good to be
true gotta be he's lying to us what's
the catch here's the deal there is no
catch they cut out the middleman pass
the savings right on to you phone sounds
clear as a bell yeah guys it's the first
company to sell wireless service online
only they cut out the cost of retail
stores and pass those sweet sweet
savings directly onto your sweet ass uh
i've been saying it for you my wife has
used mint mobile for years ryan zone
just owns the jordan
wait you're like deadpool you don't like
van wilder what are we doing here i know
he's a good looking kid it's fantastic
uh it's easy peasy send it right to your
door you play on bob boom set it all up
keep your phone keep the numbers
any anxiety or worry that you have about
switching completely out the window with
mint mobile uh for anyone who hates
their phone bill mint mobile offers
premium wireless service for just 15 15
clams 15 bucks 15 shekels a month mint
mobile gives you the best rate whether
you're buying one or a family and mint
mobile family started two lines that's
how they beat this yeah i'm locked into
a family pan meanwhile with the with
with the big guys they're putting me
over a barrel oh yeah dude it's you you
you might be stuck with your your big
box wireless until like 2088 so it's a
sucker to get your new wireless plan for
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's mint
mobile.com garbage call your wireless
boat to 15 bucks a month mintmobile.com
such garbage do it but man i went right
back to being like cut about that you
feel and i go just own the situation
this woman thinks i'm poor i just had to
[ __ ] take it yeah we can do multiple
forms then i whipped out the other
credit card that i just got approved for
for the miles uh-huh i opened it up it's
what is the barclays
that's a personal
that's perfect it's all personal i'm not
buying freaking hey whatever you want to
do
hey okay they called me for approval
hello
uh so yeah it was just one of those like
[ __ ]
gut i was just like [ __ ] this is this
sucks yeah sucks it's a tough luck man i
got i'm just bad i've always been bad
with money and i always will be
[ __ ] stink around i i make sure
i don't walk into a situation blind
anymore i know i make sure i know and if
it's a high pressure situation i'm
probably going to take the finals what
do you mean
it was game seven
no i took the i took the fam out to
dinner uh this was months ago and i made
sure that i had enough action you run it
after every course all right all right
take that here here bring the checkout
let's get the appetizers out of the way
i couldn't find the entrees
wait a minute
all right guy with the cheesecake
oh pay as you go
[Laughter]
no i made sure i had the money
because that would have been an
embarrassing situation
sure yeah i made sure i had the money
the actual money on me on you yeah yeah
and then put it on the credit card
mm-hmm then immediately ran to the bank
the next day to try to get it back in
there
but i can't go to a navy federal so i
got to do a three
three-step process sure it's a
three-card monthly with you yeah i got
to put it my girl's got a deposit venmo
it to me and then get it over to navy
federal that's real [ __ ] trashy yeah
go through the panama canal as i call it
uh-huh but good stuff uh that being said
this is a uh family episode guys on a
family episode uh when you join a
patreon we will ask your garbage
question over there and how [ __ ]
fitting this one's from nick first time
long time
how about putting huge group meals on
your card to feel good about yourself
because then you collect the venmo and
it feels like you have a lot yeah feels
like you're eating for free he goes yeah
if you put a big thing and then you get
everybody sends you money and you got
like 450 sitting in the venmo what's the
timeline on that on what i don't operate
like that sure i don't operate like that
okay either paying we split it whatever
but i guess i would i just don't have
that many friends i was going to say
it's not like a grit it's not like uh
you're so generous that you've never
been out to eat with anybody that hasn't
been your parents yeah it's true or me
yeah
um
you go out to a situation like that
all right
couple couples whatever it is what's the
timeline okay you're paying here you go
here it is all right it came to 30
it came to 70 dollars a person okay
when do you need that money by
do i not need it but at the table by the
time i'm finished my coffee what are you
talking about i i need it before we
[ __ ] leave um no
uh at the table at the table i would do
it if i if somebody put it on their card
i would pull out my phone and go here
cause i'm i'm notoriously bad at those
things because i've never had money
so i would always be like i'll get you
tomorrow yeah when i get home so like i
always try to kick the can down the road
a little bit because i need a little
[ __ ] breathing room i need after
dinner drink money see
tomorrow i know you got no money because
there's no reason why
you can't do it right then and there uh
the royal you sure
but there's that there's also the thing
of like that's a bit tacky of like
no you don't ask yeah i know i'm just
saying it but i'm saying if you if if if
if you but there's also the the the
position of it if like if if i went out
that
if you're upset that i didn't pull my
phone out and send it to you immediately
while we're sitting there digesting
having a [ __ ] a nice cup of coffee
that's a little tacky on your part i
don't think so don't make the offer then
go let's split it
you can't be like hey run my card i'll
[ __ ] give me the money right now timo
what do you think
if you're
venmo requesting
no no no no you can't send nobody listen
i have an uncouth [ __ ] bonehead never
would i say unless you owed me 12 grand
i would never send a venmo request
yeah i couldn't i couldn't send a memo
request
that's just me though and also i'm
horrible with money
somebody might have asked me to do it
which was weird i don't know if i did it
maybe like a booker or a promoter i'll
do that now so somebody like send me the
request if you know i have maybe done
that or i'll tell people to send me the
request yeah so i can find that way it's
easier i know i'm sending it to the
right person 24 hours you have 24 hours
24 hours 24 hours yeah yeah see i i i
don't
i don't see why that's not something
that can't be done at the table if
because you're because then what hold on
then what benefit are my not benefit but
like why don't we just split it then see
what i'm saying if you went into the
meal preparing to if it's if it's a
convenience thing of like oh here i got
it but everybody has one of them hold on
everybody has their phones on them at
all times i know i also have my credit
card on me at all times right yeah so
you me
the only reason you would one person
would be doing it to make it easy for
the server that's what you're doing it
for yeah but it's also like a vibe thing
i'm like all right here i got it don't
don't sweat it the conversation's still
going on
you're hanging uh-huh you know that's
the way i see it all right like hey boom
you got 24 hours after 24 hours
i know that i would i wouldn't say
anything i would say but i would i'd be
judging
well see that's on you yeah that's what
i'm saying that's awesome we went out to
dinner with 10 people yeah but then you
can't go like oh i got it and then just
start immediately [ __ ] hit a clock
and start judging people on how quick
they [ __ ] pay you back that's what a
psychopath does well
you sh it should be done out of
generosity of like hey
let's not [ __ ] [ __ ] up the vibe here
i got it there you go let's keep hanging
and talking otherwise everybody just go
get your card out and [ __ ] split it
you're saving if you're if it's a two
cards if it's a couple two couples
you're saving the you're saving the
weight you're the waiter or the waitress
five seconds okay
i mean yeah it's different if it's like
17 i would say more than not the people
that don't do it that night or the next
morning are the dirt bags of the of the
squad would you agree with me on that
i don't necessarily
have you ever not sent it
no
i've definitely kicked it down the road
a while once a while
a week i don't know i don't know i
genuinely do christmases
i'm gonna get you buddy
um i genuinely don't know
but there's that's also i don't like
that that you'd pay and then you start
judging how trashy people are yeah no
that's that's trashy it should be done
out of the generosity of your heart
otherwise let's [ __ ] split it and
then you're putting yourself in a
position of power
yeah i thought that was the whole point
of this of what life yeah no what do you
mean to have good times plus i get extra
bites of the dessert
yeah see then you're then you're you try
to be i'm the only one that's allowed to
use a table i don't think and don't
think i haven't seen you this last road
trip really [ __ ] nudging me out of
the way to pay and look like the cool
guy of course yeah i got that platinum
card yeah it's all coming from the same
spot i know oh oh hard feelings we're
going to save it oh buddy save it i got
a [ __ ] bullseye wait i got a bullet
with your name on it are you kidding me
what i think i know what you're going to
start dabbling into okay we'll save it
yeah we're gonna um see you in about 20
minutes
uh also we were just kind of talking
about this from harley dallas hutton
first time writer and 10 dollar homie
uh which is the correct way to make a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich peanut
butter on both sides or one side of the
bread
it's one in one i would presume i'm a
peanut butter man straight up stop
slow down
one of the greatest questions ever asked
it's good i love it
now
it's got to be one and one
i mean
what are we doing here maybe throw a
little j in there for jeff
yeah or ayg number one you start with
fresh bread you could do whole wheat or
you could do white yeah
who's not using fresh bread for a
[ __ ] peanut butter and jelly sandwich
patty foley from 84 to 97. cutting the
[ __ ] mold off the corner that's who
um
peanut butter's soft because it's in the
cabinet right t-bone that's correct
right we learned that the hard way at
the foley household it's ripping through
about about 10 years of that that's
crazy why wouldn't you make the exact
decision go ma we're not doing it i
didn't know i didn't know that that's
why it was hard
that's how stupid we haven't gone over
someone else's house and been like i
never why aren't there holes in your
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
this is crazy i never put two and two
together
i swear to god
we didn't start taking it out of the
fridge until i was probably in high
school
had everything the jelly in there
[ __ ] butter and [ __ ] in it crumbs
yeah it was wild eat it but yes
room temperature peanut butter one side
okay then you take the knife to the
other piece of bread clean it clean it
then you go into the jelly and put the
jelly on that side close it up now do
you cut it in half never
back in the day you did
not if i was making it really my mom
wouldn't cut i think my stepmom used to
cut them
stepmom you just got the mom never did
always cut it
diagonal if you could that was fancy
yeah right would it be the [ __ ]
rockefellers cutting their sandwiches
diagonal that's [ __ ] wild
i know man my mom never did it didn't
cost any money but still was what rich
people did yeah we're servants you look
like
you put jeffrey from [ __ ] fresh
prince the sandwich looked more salt of
the earth if you cut it straight across
yeah it looks way smaller too yeah so
where the [ __ ] where'd the other half go
what's going on
this thing was [ __ ] normal size a
minute ago would you have your mom cut
your crust off kip i could see you doing
that till about 17 18. you're nuts never
love the crust crust is big big crust
guy
get rid of that [ __ ] you didn't like the
crust not when i was a kid what i might
as well have been you're going to sit
here and judge me you were a no-crust
sandwich
that might as well been a cigar wrapper
i was a kid you're crazy hey honey do me
a favor i want you to take this plate
run back to the kitchen get this
[ __ ] off and bring this back to me
okay i'm never gonna look at you this
day you've admitted a lot of things
that's why i didn't like the crust when
i was a little kid it was too [ __ ] it
was a [ __ ] it was too dark yeah it was
burnt i didn't like it i
learned to love it i love it now i'm all
crossed
i'll just i've seen your underwear
no
i can't you're going to say i want to
open a restaurant called just crust or
always surface crust you're going to sit
here
the two ends what are you talking about
you've lost all streaks
right now you've lost all street cred
not having your [ __ ] mom
cut off the crust for your [ __ ] ass
that's wild you little [ __ ] [ __ ]
running around with stains in your
underoos i think my father went and gave
me that exact same speech one time yeah
you deserved it too how old
uh when did i start [ __ ] with crust
that's a shame man
pre-teen
i would say up until 10 11. that's like
an eight-year-old still drinking their
mom's boob because yeah i was smoking
cigs at that time dude and you were
afraid of crust
you weren't smoking six at ten eleven
no yeah it was
whatever
second hand but still
how about the gyros
[Laughter]
casual dining joint
yeah wow yeah i didn't like the crust
that's some real push [ __ ] and i always
wanted strawberry jelly never got
strawberry my cousin strawberry straw
everybody had strawberry we were [ __ ]
grape jelly not even grape jam
big strawberry jam guy okay every once
in a while she'd have a
uh an orange marmalade in there for the
wet and wooly or the air apple
what what's that a sex party the wet and
wild i told you about that wet and wooly
it's a it's a trashy i don't know what
you're saying wet and woolly
wet and wooly wet and woolly it's a dip
it's a party dip
it's it's apple it's apple marmalade or
orange marmalade and horseradish and you
you put that over a brick of cream
cheese
and dip wheat thins or ritz crackers in
it
top shelf i i know that i don't know
what i said it's called wet and wooly
pop and molly what are you doing
yeah wet and wooly
that and the crab one we used to do too
what's the crab one you get a can of
crab meat like real the real crap good
stuff
jesus and you mix that like crab beef
you mixed that with cocktails what do
you want longshoremen
can't get a candy crab meat okay so get
some bread not to stop with the mold
they sell good crab meat and cans
for dips and things who's they the
government not a bumblebee i don't know
who's ever pulling the strings no and
you mix it you take i got the chicken in
a can though got me through college
chicken in the cans all right yeah it
ain't too shabby
i almost prefer it over tuner
if we cut oh i mean yeah i don't [ __ ]
with tuna but the smell alone oh really
i would have to
take in the trash out as a little kid
and there'd be [ __ ]
can of tuna in the recyclables make me
want to puke
stuff do gummy bears on your nose
probably clean out the recycle bottom
[Laughter]
dude i dude tuner will still get me if
i can't
yeah man
i might as well be like mustard gas dude
that's just
hung around too canned dog food did that
to me
dude
holy [ __ ] i never understood canned dog
food oh i got some of my sweaters you
were always dry oh he had some on my
sweater i did it'll be christmas it
smelled for about six months i had my
mom wash it like a thousand times
oh but anyway you get a can of crab meat
you mix it with cocktail sauce and you
pour that over a brick of cream cheese
dip your
yeah
shout out to my cousin
cousin's hollywood uh christmas party oh
you guys really getting after it yeah we
do
all right this one's for me and first
time long time do you have any loose
teeth as an
adult no i got them all knocked out ah
that's bad if you got if you got a if
you got a wobbly incisor that is a tough
look yeah i had it for a while things
stuck really
yeah remember i remember a bit i thought
it was loose no but for it was it was
they were loose the one was loose for
like two months and i would play with it
and suck on it and stuff like that
you suck on it you're a [ __ ]
weird dude i've never smelled it when
they pulled it out
oh damn do you ever catch one of those
food balls
that's the little like it's like a piece
of food yeah they get stuck like in your
tonsil stones
it's like maybe it's like it's food it
smells like [ __ ] oh yeah probably i
thought i was dying dude i was in like
fifth grade or something like fascinated
with them when i was a kid i'm like what
they coughed and i was like what the
[ __ ] is that on your finger and then
it's not that bad when it's solid once
you smoosh it it smells like straight
poop i almost told my dad i was like
dude i think i'm dying like that just
came out of me i'm like that ain't good
hachimachi
yeah shout out to a tonsil stone all
right this one's the jerk store ever
flip one sig upside down and a fresh
pack of bernies and call it your lucky
cig no but people did that all the time
that was usually a pretty trashy girl
thing yeah girls yeah definitely did
that that and people were scared of
white lighters
oh i'll still not really [ __ ] with a
white lighter yeah i wouldn't take one
on a plane
what are you breaking a lighter on a
plate oh i mean i used to catch [ __ ]
heaters heavy bike you don't remember
smoking them on a plane not smoking on a
plane okay
um
you don't
remember say once you start smoking
right after my mom started cutting the
crust off my [ __ ] sandwiches
i don't think that's a non-manly thing i
was a little kid
uh-uh you weren't eating crust the whole
time there's no way yeah well i never
remember the crust being cut off and
what about you tippy toes
tippy toes yeah look at look at you
trying to spin this thing yeah but toby
did it
absolutely not no yeah no i'm gonna ask
your mom
that's some whack-ass [ __ ] catch you in
a lie
all right would you have toast when you
were a kid
yes
rye toast i didn't start eating until
later in a game i thought that was i
thought that was like [ __ ] european
or something i didn't my dad when my dad
moved out he started keeping rye toast
and i was like
whoa i don't think so big fan of rye nah
i get never cut the crust off that no
never no loved it
shout out to rye breads are right dude
rye bread at a diner you go out you go
out to breakfast get rye bread in the
diet it's the best at home toasted cause
you can really control it you gotta get
that golden brown
crispy but you know what i'm not a big
fan of and i was thinking about this the
other day for some reason
is the patty melt
patty melt can kick rocks if you're not
familiar with the paddy mountain patty
mode is a burger
that has cheese on it caramelized onions
and it's done on rye bread like uh like
a grilled cheese toby terrible terrible
absolute dog they suck i've never had a
[ __ ] good one and i've been suckered
into buying them many dimes
i just keep going back but they always
stink
sounds great sounds like it would be
good you'd think it would be yeah in the
dust bowl
yeah i don't know
i'm in
um
i think i did flip a sig every night
there was might have been like a summer
when i was doing it
because it's like i've been ocd so like
once it's in matthew's phase no never
once it's in your head you like
i can't not do it if i think about it
you know what i mean every pack of
marlboro 27s as a lucky segue sure yeah
let me be following them off your buddy
i think pat used to do it a lot don't
take my lucky one yeah oh you only got
the one left
yeah no no
not for me trash um all right let's see
here
well this one we did we talked about
right but this is from i just want to
give a shout out from peppers uh he said
for our next patreon goal we should do a
full-on storage war
and that's what we're doing well what if
we do you buy one i buy one and then
whoever gets the most money out of it or
something that might be pretty crazy
yeah let's just rip off storage wars
no but i feel we should go buy one or we
should just buy one together at the very
least we gotta go drive prices
sky high
i like the competition
but how do we value what things are
worth you have to sell it there's a lot
of work well i'm just listing [ __ ] on
ebay on the show on the show they're so
full of [ __ ] like oh that's 50 here 20
get the [ __ ] out of here
nobody's paying [ __ ] 50 bucks for
[ __ ] uh pool balls where you're
missing the nine ball get out of here
yeah yeah yeah they're so full of [ __ ]
that show was good in the early seasons
though yep yeah what are you gonna do
with that [ __ ] just throw it out after
we get it
i don't know i guess lock it up never
pay the bill and just have them resell
it
come back again low ball them
what if we what if we find something
that's i mean this is all i've ever
wanted to do i told you i've
that's what you were gonna do i kicked
the tires on them a little bit really
yeah i used to work right next to one
an office that i worked out i don't
think you told me this no i have i was
right next to one and they would be
there and i'd be
you know i didn't have any if i had some
scratch hole i'd [ __ ] toss my hat in
the ring i fully i would imagine his
like big win would be like an original
star wars figurine
no [ __ ] [ __ ] two golden bars or
something what the [ __ ] are you talking
about buying my own toys yeah db coupe
where are you at
i'm looking for the necklace that old
broadhead and the titanic
the tuna of the sea or whatever it was
get my hands on that thing opals
diamonds
that's what i'm all about um all right
this one's from alex thomas 10 hey me do
you still pop the safeties off a bic
lighter that's a bad look they don't
really have them anymore
it's the metals well it's the metal
thing i don't know if you can get that
off the crack headlighters don't have
that isn't it is that what you call them
right they're called the crackhead
lighters what do you mean that's just
they're synonymously known as crack
headlights anything that's not the
shitty ones yeah yeah they're like they
used to be as [ __ ] or whatever you know
yeah 50 cents those you just ripped it
the clear one
torch them yeah [ __ ] lift it up turn
that wheel get in the pipe there
then you would get you would
you would rig them that's what we call
rigging you know
rigged the lighter you would rig it so
much and then it would explode would hit
its
it would like release too much gas or
something and it would [ __ ] explode
in your hand i never had that we had to
light the long flame though that would
get you yeah but you didn't realize that
you got to hit a [ __ ] barrier take
the eyebrows off yeah cause you're
walking into a sorority house looking
like a bozo
missing an eyebrow what's up what's your
major
um
you chicks got ointment
yeah where's your eu sporometer
sporum
big neosporum house
what are you saying neosporum that's not
what it is yes it is spore in
neosporin all right neil sporn we called
neosporum
also too
sounds like a kid i don't know if we've
discussed this but my mom uh
reinvigorated it with me what do you
call the thing that you kill flies with
a flyswatter that's not what you call it
no we called it a fleischwater
i don't know why that's what we called
it a fl a fleischwater
a fleisch water is that like a fun bit
no
that's what i that's what we that's what
i thought it was called
for a long long time my mom my mom
called it a flight water
two weekends ago when i saw them or
three weekends ago when i saw them i
don't even know how to respond to that i
know it's crazy flight water get the fly
shorter
that sounds german i know
it's crazy
yeah it's absolute trash also how many
flies you got who's
that's a pro that's a product of the 80s
and 90s you shouldn't still have that
many flies in here there's a couple of
flies in the house last time i was there
yeah
yeah
i don't think we've ever owned the fly
swatter
down to sure you would
no we always those green heads would
come in you know what i always wanted
the salt gun
no
those things are nasty pat had one how
are those legal what i mean you're
you're knocking everything off the table
with that what do you mean but those
things i don't know what i think i don't
think we're on this it sprays it sprays
it's not just gonna hit the fly it's
gonna smash a window or something it's
not coming out that quick the one guy
did it it broke skin
broke skin on a guy no that's not gonna
break a window i don't know
seemed pretty dicey but i was going to
say the electric i don't believe any of
this the electric bug zapper
oh yeah
man yeah we stayed at a cabin that had
one one time catch a big one of those
families that had those was pure garbage
yeah you shouldn't have that many bugs
if you lived in the country or whatever
that's one thing you have it on the
porch whatever that's something you know
but you shouldn't have that many bugs in
the house you know what that's a
regional you don't have those things in
the house around the house there's
something you're not keeping up on a
property or something if you've got an
electric bug zapper in the kitchen
i think he did in waterboy
that's a tough look
but for a while in the 90s
and this worked like a charm
uh everybody had this thing in the
backyard to collect beetles oh the bags
dude yeah they would get a [ __ ] heavy
bike dude that was like a [ __ ] denzel
movie i don't know what how did they get
in there got to be some oil in the bag
it worked so [ __ ] good why would that
why was that a problem that was all
again i don't know nobody has those now
those beetle bags no but those beetles
are around we always i always find them
in the pool i i take them out and let
them soak them around but they're not a
problem they seem to be a problem if you
were catching them by the [ __ ] potato
yeah they were back in the day i think
they looked at their moment they were
the they were the lanternfly of the 90s
but you know what when i i feel bad
for the aggression that i put towards
those beetles because they never did
anything they don't do something though
no they don't bite i didn't like them
they would die they'd be all crusty yeah
they scared the [ __ ] out of you it's the
exoskeleton on them now i don't think so
they were scary but they don't do
anything i save them now in the pool
yeah hitting the lightning bugs with a
wiffle ball bat was one of my
all-time favorite things wow that's
pretty crazy never killed lightning bugs
really no my cousin used to make neck
jewelry out of him though what yeah i
was pretty [ __ ] up net jewelry
you made jewelry out of them should get
a piece of get a piece of grass oh sure
and like you know just rip off the butt
and put it around yeah you smoosh it
like put it under your eyes and stuff i
just thought it was inhumane i love
lightning bugs lightning bugs and
dragonflies are my two favorites
dragonflies love a dragon
i don't know if i ever told you the
story we were staying in a motel
uh
in north wildwood my mom wasn't there it
was me my aunt my like my mom was
probably working on the weekend and sent
me down with my aunt
we were staying in i get i think she had
a hotel for like the month like a mo
like one of those motels you can rent
for the month or the season yikes
oh she had it was great you'd sit out on
that balcony you know there's like real
like you're just sitting next to your
door and then it's like the window and
then another door and every every
building every uh unit had a chair out
front sit on that go swimming there i
[ __ ] loved it but
uh
my cousin was staying there as well and
if i was probably 10 she was
maybe 20 something like that 18 19. i'm
listening and she had a boy she was
dating the guy so he was there in the
kitchen there was like 10 of us in this
[ __ ] assistant yeah we're real
[ __ ] there you're staying with your
aunt her daughter and his boyfriend's
there
yeah i guess yikes or maybe are they
happy that might have had their own
whatever i forget the i forget the
logistics of it i just remember being in
a motel
with this dude who i did i think blocked
it out as the rig correct there
and a dry he went into the he went into
the kitchen and a dragonfly [ __ ] was
in there and he [ __ ] pat it scared
this [ __ ] dude he jumped out the second
story window of the kitchen
and i was like dude i watched him go out
the window that's how afraid of it it
like flew out of the sink or something
he [ __ ] and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i
gotta be like [ __ ] steve just [ __ ] he
came back up to the front door i was
like what the [ __ ]
i've nev that was the first time i saw
anybody proper panic
like proper lose their [ __ ]
risking my body to jump out of a motel
room window
i remember how the [ __ ] did he not die
it was crazy and leave a little kid in
there
yeah he thought it was gonna kill him
he rubs peanut butter all over you and
jumps out the window needless to say
that relationship did not last yeah no
kidding
it's a real costanza move right there
i love dragonflies though and they don't
sting
dragonflies don't bite you right they
can bite you i don't think so there's
dragon in the name i feel like i've made
that joke before give that a goog um
all right this one's from julian uh is
it garbage if you consider chipotle a
healthy food option
no i don't see anything wrong with that
if you don't get the rice
right
fellas
i wouldn't say if you don't get the rice
the cheese in the sour cream but then
what are you doing
um
the bowls are a
does anybody get anything other than a
bowl there the burrito the burrito
nobody gets the tacos right i've seen
people get to talk yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um i don't know if i'd be friends with
somebody that got tacos
it's the same [ __ ] i know but it's weird
um
that's a bowl spot
sure or a burrito i would do i've done a
lot of burritos from there it i can't i
think it tends to be
not it's not a healthy option i think
would be a healthier option than other
things i would get i would put it that
way does that make sense did it get like
a [ __ ] cheesesteak and fries
i would argue a
burrito bowl is a little bit better i
always thought it was it's also to come
from two fat pieces of [ __ ] so clearly
we don't know what to [ __ ] with i always
thought it was a healthier option
healthier is not healthy though just in
comparison sure right a cheesesteak is
healthier than a cheese taking fries it
doesn't mean it's [ __ ] healthy
yeah i mean yeah
but fantastic nonetheless shout out to
chapato
burrito bowl um
let's see here
this one's from nathan what up bozo's
first time long time 10 scented trash
bag here i'll give you that
um
my question is have you ever used
chopstick for non-asian cuisine because
you ran out of clean silverware in the
house
can't say i have
no
i have 100 dipped chicken nuggets into
honey mustard utilizing chopsticks free
that makes sense though and they also
sell these little
they look like chops guests but you put
them on your fingers
you put they have two little hooks for
like uh cheetos and popcorn and stuff
like that so you don't get that stuff
all over your fingers really what i what
i just learned about chopstick is this
chopstick etiquette i didn't know was a
thing oh yeah you're not supposed to
point at stuff nope not supposed to talk
and you're not supposed to hand people
stuff with your chopsticks i've been
breaking all the rules my whole life
yeah
you're not supposed to stick it in in
the bowl either that's a big no-no it's
stick it in the bowl
like say you have like a bowl of like
poke or something like that you're not
supposed to like ge like that you're not
supposed to like jam it in like that
and like pull something out no just like
like if they rested in there yeah
there's resting
there should be like doesn't it come
with so i just learned this the
disposable
chopsticks like the little the wooden
jawns
they have that thing on the butt of them
that breaks off and that acts as a
resting thing so that's where you should
rest them does that make sense there's
like a little wooden nub
when you break it off
it looks like the top of like a jewel
pod kind of
that is a rest so you don't rest it in
the bowl or on the plate or whatever i
haven't ever seen that
yeah i mean i'm sure you have i've seen
the wooden ones where they're connected
and you snap them like a wishbone yeah
at that there's like a little nub a
little wooden nub on them huh
we would get rain out of tokyo so fast
yeah yeah i'd be asking for spoons and
forks and it's bad i don't know how to
use them i can like kind of get by i
love them but not i'm just
the first time i used one was probably
like i'm not even [ __ ] around like
when i hadn't met my wife was the first
time i used one i was i was trying not
to be embarrassed i'm getting pretty
good yeah big korean barbecue guy
huge
[ __ ] oh it's so good
yeah it's so good i don't know
it's just a convenience thing to me and
i know it's uncultured and everything
i'm like
just give me a fork what are we doing
here a bowl of ramen with a fork is
pretty banging though because you really
get the noodles that's what i'm saying
why am i [ __ ] like a bird over here
let's go
give me a backhoe baby let me [ __ ]
[ __ ] move some earth with that thing
you really get the noodles like eating
spaghetti
yeah um all right let's do a couple mo
here
um
this is from lady boner for t-boner
you ever tear off the first few pieces
of toilet paper at a public restroom
because it's
quote-unquote contaminated what a
fantastic question from the probably the
greatest
listener i'm sure he's a great looking
guy
i see what she said do it all the time
if i'm using it to put on my face like
if i have to blow my nose or something
okay yeah i'll
i do it regardless i take i might even
use that to clean but i usually just a
couple pieces in the bowl and then i
start my process really yeah okay
because if those are contaminated
i don't know what
i mean theoretically everything in that
stall has particles on sure i'm just
trying to try to try to you know limit
the hemorrhaging you know what i mean
get through your day
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah sure uh if they made a
product like night vision goggles that
would show you all of the germs would
you use them they have that it's a black
light absolutely not not everything
shows up on a black light but absolutely
not i
that's i'd have to
[ __ ] jump off a bridge
i wouldn't be able to do it it's already
i already think it's bad
and what
i know that's why i don't worry about
the toilet paper on the seat or anything
like that it's all it's like that and
you're also a [ __ ]
dirt bag we're all one thing you think
that that we are not the same you think
okay we are not the same you think
there's air between us it's molecules
and atoms and skin cells and it's ether
we're all we're we're all one thing it's
all everywhere i don't even know what
you're talking i don't think you know
what you're talking about get some
neosporum for this guy
[ __ ] bozo
we just had to teach you how [ __ ] a
hot spot on a phone works i'm not
listening to you about [ __ ] particles
chopsticks
use them good
you ain't got [ __ ] nose hair out of
you
well ain't that good using me to patty
melt next time
boo
patty belts stink um all right let's see
here
this one's from
brisby
okay all right
is a garbage have two baby teeth in your
mid 30s
what the [ __ ] that's that's like that
that's crazy that's
not good
how's that it's like next to power plant
type stuff yeah didn't get enough milk
when you were a kid
where are they oh and i have so many
follow-up questions that i also don't
want to know the answer to i knew a kid
that uh
his parents would give him milk when he
went to bed and it [ __ ] his teeth up
what do you mean they would get like
give him a bottle of actual milk when he
went to bed and that does something to
the kids teeth
when you're a baby or something like
that i don't know his were all jacked up
like like rotted out of his mouth his
baby teeth yeah that's not i'm telling
you it's not milk t-bone give it a goog
babies with milk going to bed with a
bottle something like that milk on their
teeth
that's like also not brushing your teeth
though
kids drink milk all the time when they
go to bed
all they get is milk go to bed that's a
thing damn all types of milk can cause
cavities if they are inappropriately
consumed
uh if a baby
for example cavities on the upper front
teeth can develop if a baby with teeth
is put to bed at night with a bottle of
can't win buddy
you're telling me yeah but that but they
also have to not be brushing your teeth
or something doesn't say anything about
that doesn't do how many kids drink milk
when they go to bed uh there's got to be
a lot of kids the the photo is in black
and white so i see all right 1920s
problem this is before [ __ ] crest was
banging what are you talking about
colgate arm and hammer
yeah maybe back in your you know you
need fluoride the only place you can get
that's the gummy
yeah i mean i i it might not be good for
it but it's also like
oh don't all kids drink milk and bottle
that's what goes in bottles is milk not
not not women's milk cow milk
i'm not talking about lady milk yeah but
no
i think a lot of people still drink cow
milk
bottles
i would argue that's formula idiot what
are you talking about they're not giving
kids milk babies drink formula yeah how
old was this kid i don't know it has
baby teeth so you know i mean
it's not like he was a taut toddler you
wouldn't know him maybe he was a toddler
they were giving him a bottle of milk to
go to sleep at night
and taking it with him but also as a
toddler you wouldn't go like oh this
guy's teeth are all [ __ ] up you're a
toddler
i would be aware of it i remember it was
a thing
i'm telling you man okay t-bone just
backed me up and so did google yeah with
science from before 1922. i don't know
how far do you have to scroll down
uh about 1918.
[Laughter]
i'm not saying you're wrong
i'm just saying i feel like that would
be a way bigger i feel like a lot of
kids drink milk no i don't am i wrong on
that i i don't think you're supposed to
give kids milk when they go to bed cow's
milk
okay i'm not talking about formula
yeah what i'm say
okay
i don't know i guess in my head i
thought this kid was like eight or
something like that
why would he have a bottle
uh that's another situation
i don't know yeah no for sure did you
have your wisdom teeth out no i think
they're bad too yeah mine are creeping i
feel them yeah i felt them for years i
got one back here that comes in every
once in a while it hurts like a
[ __ ] uh this is from john wilkes
booth never had one read are you garbage
if you have to wipe your feet before you
put your socks on because there's 100
100 chance that the bottoms are covered
in crumbs
found myself doing that today actually
you got to give it like a quick little
whatever's on there i guess the dog hair
is tough though and keep the floors
clean mm-hmm
i've had a bunch of [ __ ] on my socks
that i've had to wipe them off before i
put them in my shoes
they're covered in [ __ ] cat hair and
[ __ ] yeah you got to give them a quick
like [ __ ] yeah
quick little tussle how you doing get
the get this get the stuff off yeah
having when you're walking around your
house barefoot and you look at your feet
and they're like dark on the bottom
that's a tough look
get the schwiffer will you i know but
the problem is it doesn't have to
visually look bad for you to be like oh
[ __ ] for that to happen no your same
time so it's like if you're like oh yeah
it's clean then you're like oh it is
yeah it looks like you were walking
through [ __ ]
parking lot at a fish concert
[Laughter]
walking around woodstock all zoomed out
all right but we got to wrap her up here
gang gang we love you to death come see
us at the old live shows there come out
grab the squad come and see us check out
the patreon we love you and we'll see
you next week peace